it has been absolutely extraordinary
it's a day some had thought maybe tre a
drop in the level of commitment to this
Pro democracy movement in Hong Kong
those doubters could not have been more
wrong
Victoria Park the venue it only holds
150,000 people or so it was filled to
bursting before the rally was due to
even start tens then hundreds of
thousands descended on this high-end
part of Hong Kong Island determined to
be there to show their solidarity
they're queued to get into the entrances
as the heavens opened the rain lashed
down the umbrellas very much the emblem
of protest here were opened with the
park at absolute capacity the late
arrivals filled the streets as far as
the eye could see from overwatch
positions we filmed these remarkable
images people around us gasped at the
size of the crowd the sheer numbers
marching and chanting no pushing or
shoving and no violence a rally in peace
defying police bands and government
condemnation the Beijing and Hong Kong
administrations knew they had a problem
after a week marred by violence they
really know they have a problem now this
is absolute defiance in an absolute
demand to be heard
[Applause]
the government is eventually going to
listen the people had no intention of
staying put so began an enormous
sometimes chaotic but always
good-natured March in the pouring rain
roads in every direction choke the
demonstrators some of the city's largest
streets were filled to bursting it was
almost impossible to go against this
tide of humanity underground stations
was simply overrun well the police had
attempted to ban this demonstration from
turning into a March but they've
completely failed the numbers are
absolutely vast
there's a room in the park so they have
to come to the streets and they're
marching after all these weeks once
again to reaffirm their position that
they want changes here and they want the
government of Hong Kong and Beijing to
listen incredibly the shops in Causeway
Bay remain open as the March continued
we were pushed through the doors of a
super upmarket shopping mall nobody
could stem this crowd but they tried to
observe the rules at least then onwards
past the islands huge skyscrapers the
crowd determined to be listened to after
hours on the move their numbers still
fill the street a remarkable event that
won't be forgotten in Hong Kong nor in
Beijing either mister Ramsay Sky News
Hong Kong